there's an alchemy to recognition when
you see yourself and that
something happens something chemical
happens it's it's a little bit like
magic it's a validation of like i exist
[Music]
why people get to be well-rounded in the
media they get to be everything they get
to be everyone and everything what about
the rest of us
we just have to be made or we just have
to be servants we have to be slaves we
have to be
serving you
so i graduated from boston university i
went to oxford to study
shakespeare and then i got to chicago i
moved to chicago and i was like i'm
going to be an actor now and all the
roles i was getting were named maria
first of all and most of the most of the
things i had to say are like just mr
jones through here like that's all they
wanted from me
the interesting thing about the way
an entire group of people are portrayed
in film and television is that people
tend to believe that subconsciously
that tells me where my place in life is
people have gotten away with not knowing
how to work with people of color because
they've never really had to
with the beauty industry you know for
them not to typecast us as being the
class of women that are afraid to wear
color oh no no no like all this color is
invented like you can't tell me i can't
have it and also i will not be trained
to believe that i'm not worthy of it the
perception is that one color works for
all black has different shades
there's 27 countries that make up the
latin diaspora we're not one thing
sometimes they brown face me too much or
like orange me or they wipe me out i
hate when people start contouring my
nose and i didn't ask for it like why is
my face not good enough for you this is
just my face
i love this palette
looking
gorgeous it's great
you're starting to see more people of
color as directors as eps grips
screenwriters makeup artists and i think
that we are coming along but i do think
that we have a very long way to go
i feel things changing and i'm grateful
for that change as a black woman there
are a lot more voices in the industry
that sound like mine that feel true and
honest to not just me
but to my mother and my aunt and
the community that raised me
i'm creating a latina show where latinas
at the center and the forefront and i
wanted it to look like we look
you can be beautiful with whatever
feature that you have tall dark wide
nose big lips plus size petite makeup
should be used as a tool as a tool to
enhance
when my makeup is done correctly i feel
like i'm being valued as an artist and
then the character is being valued as a
human
you